hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll as you've heard climate change
is happening the earth is getting warmer
in various other aspects of our climate
our ecosystem are being affected and
human activity is an extremely important
the most important cause of it this much
is scientifically clear but as you've
also undoubtedly heard not everyone
agrees with this not everyone accepts
the scientific evidence this is
especially true in the United States
where there's a powerful movement that
denies the scientific consensus on
climate change you can even go to
Wikipedia and there's a whole page on
climate change at denial so one can ask
the question where did this come from
why especially here in the United States
and today's guest Naomi Oreskes is an
historian of science who has
investigated this question she's the
co-author of a very influential book
merchants of doubt' which was later made
into a documentary film and I'm not
gonna give away too much of what we
talked about because it's a fascinating
road to go down but one of the most
interesting aspects of the story is that
a lot of the climate denial movement can
be traced to a small number of
scientists who are also involved in
other denialists movements like denying
that smoking causes cancer why did these
people choose to make this their life's
cause the story is tied up with issues
of capitalism and communism and the Cold
War and it's just an incredibly
interesting intricate story that was
worth following up on so we're gonna
talk about that I talked about that with
Naomi and also how things have evolved
since merchants of doubt' was published
it's a very important look at how our
discourse is shaped one that is only
going to become more relevant to social
policy and communication policy as time
goes on so let's go
[Music]
Naomi Oreskes thank you so much for
being spawn cast welcome pleasure to be
here with you now you work in areas
about you know history of science but
specifically disinformation controversy
people going against the consensus and
these days we're in a world with a lot
of people are talking about fake news
and controversies over what's a
scientific fact and so forth it gets all
depressing at some point right I mean
how did you get into this intentionally
or did you just kind of stumble into it
or you dragged into it no no no I
definitely and I don't I don't really
think of myself as working on
disinformation I think of what I work on
is actually knowledge production so I
became a historian of science about 30
years ago I started as a scientist but I
was interested in what we would broadly
call broader questions about science and
society and one thing I became
interested in early on was the question
of how do scientists decide when they
have enough evidence when we have enough
evidence to say that we know something
okay because you know where when you're
studying science you're presented with
all this information you said you're
told there are these interesting
different things going on but nobody
really ever talks about how scientists
decided you know okay we know this thing
now there's a threshold yeah there's
some special who decides who votes
exactly in science isn't an election
right and as it happened I started
college in 1976 I'm dating myself now
you can do the arithmetic but the
interesting thing about 1976 in earth
science was it was just a few years
after the plate tectonics revolution and
so it was a very interesting time to be
an undergraduate because our professors
were all very excited and told us how
lucky we were to be coming into this
field now that this huge new great
theory had been developed and there were
so many things we understood property
now that we didn't understand before and
I remember thinking oh but I actually
feel like that means we've come late
like it would have been better to have
been there evaporates but that's
actually not how the professor's
presented it interestingly enough but
then I had the opportunity to travel and
study abroad and I discovered an
interesting fact which was that
the same idea the idea of moving
continents had been proposed in 1910s by
Alfred Vega and the idea had been
rejected and so that was kind of an
interesting thing well why did we reject
this idea 60 years ago and now we're
saying it's right and I also found that
in England people viewed plate tectonics
much less as a revolution and much more
as a kind of evolution from the
continental drift debate so a few years
later when I was in grad school I
decided to just take a philosophy of
science class as you say did my case
yeah exactly and so I had to write term
paper and so I proposed to my professors
I would like to write a paper about this
question well ten years later or more
than that my first book that ended up
being my PhD my first book project and
so that's what I'm really interested in
what does even mean to say that
something constitutes scientific
evidence why do scientists like some
kind of evidence better than others and
the other thing I experienced in
graduate school was that scientists
sometimes get very hot under the collar
about you know the right way to do
science and often those opinions seem to
me to be quite poorly substantiated by
history or philosophy or any kind of
real intellectual argument people would
say oh don't do that that's bad science
or you would hear professors say or
sometimes you hear physicists dismiss
the entire field of geology you know a
stamp collecting descriptive blah blah
blah and I thought well this is first of
all this ridiculous challenge is a
science you know we're clearly a science
and we deserve to be treated with
respect even if we do things differently
Darwin one of the greatest scientists of
all time was inspired by geology
originally wanted to be a geologist and
actually considered himself to be a
geologist so to say that you can't do
rigorous work in an observational mode
flies in the face of this your science
but yet you would hear you know some
people not to bash physicists but you
know this is the word start go ahead
it's like very opinionated about
methodology and so I just thought well
this is interesting this is something
that should be studied like why do they
have these strong opinions and you know
why do geologists feel defensive about
what we do even though what we do is in
and interesting and we have successfully
explained a heck of a lot of important
things about the world so anyway one
thing led to another and that's what I
do you know that's what I do did you
come to a conclusion about this question
of how we decide that something is true
is there is there a threshold or is it
just come and go no it's really a matter
of consensus and that's why I got
interested in the problem of consensus
so what I would argue now is that
scientific knowledge is the things that
scientists have agreed on and the
conditions under which they get to agree
are very historically and socially
contingent so you really cannot answer
the question of why we've decided we
know enough to say yes this is true
without actually understanding the
social context in which that discussion
takes place but it's always interesting
to me because you know as a good
Bayesian I think that you should never
be a hundred percent sure but I think
scientifically right but on the other
hand you can be so sure that you're not
going to bother to listen to contrary
claims either right right or sure enough
that it's not a good use of your time
and if somebody would come up with some
strong counter arguing based on evidence
then as a good scientist you're really
compelled to listen and in a sense that
is what happened in the plate tectonics
debate scientists rejected the idea of
continental drift for a variety of
reasons some good some in my opinion not
so good but in the 1950s when new
evidence came about they did reopen the
debate and so you know you could say
actually science worked pretty well
because in fact we did get it sorted out
you could say maybe not so well because
there was this 30 year hiatus but in my
new book that's coming out I actually
feel that 30 years later I've actually
sorted out this question that doesn't
sound too too bold of me but I actually
now think that it would have been sorted
out by the late 1930s and nearly was
sorted out there were some scientists
doing some work that they presented at a
major conference in 1936 in which they
pretty much had all the pieces of what
would later be called plate tectonics
but then world war ii broke out and all
of the key people started working on
classified military work so they got
diverted onto other things and of course
this is a perfect example of historical
contingency the war breaks out they get
asked to work on other thing
they do they're loyal Americans they
want to support the war effort and then
that but that it's but when the war ends
they don't just go back to what they
were doing before they've now been sent
on a different pathway it's not until
the 1950s that a different group of
scientists in the United Kingdom come up
with some new fresh evidence mostly from
geomagnetism and they reopen the debate
and at that point one of the key people
who had worked on this in the 30s then
he gets back involved and it then very
quickly within a very short period of
time we have plate tectonics so my
argument now is that actually the hiatus
was really a socially contingent
historically contingent thing that was
really related to World War two and that
in World War two hadn't broken out I
think we would have had the theory of
plate tectonics let's say by the 1940s
so the whole thing would have taken
maybe 2025 years and that's that's like
pretty normal for science yeah yeah so
it's not like there's some big
epistemological failure here it's more
like no scientists work in the real
world like the rest of us and they're
affected by social pressures political
developments economic issues and so
there it is
almost seems trite to say that but it's
also something that a lot of scientists
don't either don't think about it or
sometimes they actually deny it
explicitly yeah and we'd like to think
that science eventually gets the right
answer but it's not immediately that it
gets the right no it's never immediately
because there's no way it could be
because it takes time to sort out to
sort through all these different
questions and to have the arguments and
counter-arguments that you have to have
so getting back to your point absolutely
I mean no person should ever be you know
too enamored of their own conclusions in
the 1920s there was a phrase people used
to use auto intoxication is such a great
word right because we all have
colleagues who are Auto intoxicated you
know we all know what that looks like
and that's not a good thing right so
it's really important in any branch of
intellectual work to always you know be
aware of the idea that you might be
wrong but you know if scientists have
been working on an issue for 50 years
and they've pretty much looked at it
from lots of different angles and come
to the conclusion that the evidence is
overwhelming that this is correct and
maybe looked at some key issues like
with climate
science you know back in the 90s
scientists sort out this issue of
whether the observed warming could be
the Sun right these questions have been
addressed and answered so at that point
then two things happen first of all it
would frankly be a waste of time to be
doing the same thing over and over again
you want to move on that's part of why
science progresses if it can be said to
progress because we don't keep arguing
the same points all over and again and
also because in this case we have
serious decisions to make based on
climate science there's a ticking clock
there's a ticking clock and the longer
we delay the worse the consequences
become so this is a slight
out-of-left-field question but what
you're saying is making me think about
things like the individual scientists
not only do Wars get in the way but they
have intuitions they have preferences
they have things that they think are
right and so there could just be you
know an intellectual resistance all in
very good faith right but just like they
this doesn't feel right to them so
they're not going to accept it how does
have you ever thought about how
something like that plays out in
something like physics or cosmology like
with super string theory sure yeah well
I mean this is the biggest argument I
think for diversity in science and by
that I don't just mean demographic
diversity but intellectual diversity as
well I think we have good evidence from
history of science that when scientific
communities are non diverse either
demographically or intellectually and
when they are closed and tend to be sort
of a closed group of experts only
talking to each other that that is not
entirely healthy right and so that's one
of the reasons it's one of the reasons
why we have conferences and we have peer
review right we have mechanisms in
science to say okay well Sean Carroll
has this theory he thinks is right and
that's fine you can be as enthusiastic
about your theory as you want and to
some extent being enthusiastic is good
or but you know now we're not going to
take his word for it right we're going
to send this to some other reviewers
preferably people who aren't his friends
and hopefully they'll review it you know
it'll be a tough review but if they say
well you know I don't really like those
Caltech people but I think you know then
you know then you that's that's sort of
the whole point of peer review and so to
the as long as that is happening and as
long as you really do have independent
peer review and you have a diverse
community where different perspectives
can be heard
then I think most the time were in
pretty good shape yeah I think that that
sounds 100% right to me I think that the
practical issue is that if you're you
know a department hiring people right
and you're deciding which areas to hire
in and you're in principle in favor of
intellectual diversity in practice you
think no the people working on this are
just smarter and more correct and the
people working on that it's just very
hard for people to say well we think
this person is working on less
interesting things but we should hire
them anyway because of diversity reasons
yeah well that's right it is hard to do
that and so you might not expect any one
department to achieve that but the
physics community as a whole can achieve
that and if and if people are not open
to the idea that some other approaches
could be valuable and important then
that can be a problem and I think you
know you you raise string theory I'm not
an expert in string theory but you know
we both know there's been some pretty
vocal debates about whether string
theory is a good way to go or not and
that's good that that to me is taking
place it would be bad if it if it
weren't in a way yeah I find myself in a
weird position because I'm Pro string
theory I think it has a lot to offer but
I think there's maybe a bit too much of
it I think that you know it's hard for
this people in the string theory
community who by now have been divorced
from experimental data for decades yeah
to say well we need some non string
theory voices and they don't they don't
say that like they're on the right track
so I think that there's a pretty strong
argument from history that that there's
a strong counter argument against and
especially what you said a bit about
being divorced from experimental data
because you could be doing your thing
and be very convinced that you're on the
right track but as long as you have some
other people doing experimental data or
some ground truth then you know there's
some kind of tension if I can use that
word a healthy productive tension that
you're forced to engage with these other
lines of reasoning or evidence from the
reality check right exactly and I talk
about that a lot in my work that you
know in the 19th century William Huell
you used the develop this concept of
Concilium evidence and yo Wilson has
popularized it again recently and I
think that Hugh was right about that
that we can feel pretty confident about
our conclusions when we have lots of
lines of evidence that stand alone
independently preferably collected by
different people maybe in different
parts of the globe or at least each
other
like each other maybe they're from MIT
thanks but if even when people who have
different views and don't like each
other and use different methods still
come to the same conclusion then you
know you've got some pretty good grouse
to feel like this is probably pretty
good but if you've only got one group of
people and they're all doing the same
thing it's not so great and I thought
that you know so one of the things that
you've figured out noticed you know
found in your research is that just a
small number of people having contrary
in views can be put to use by these
social forces that we mentioned so how
did you first get into this specific
line of research that led to merchants
of doubt' well like most important
things was an accident so I was working
on what was going to be my full
professor book a big book on the history
of Cold War oceanography looking at the
question of what difference did it make
who was funding the science because
oceanography the United States went from
being almost non-existent in the early
20th century to being a very well
developed science but it's in the 1950s
and that was almost entirely the result
of military funding during the Cold War
because of the significance of
oceanography for anti-submarine warfare
so that seemed like you know in history
we don't have controlled experiments but
that was a sort of as close to one as I
could get where you had this very clear
change so I was working on this and one
of the things the narrative arc sort of
begins at Woods Hole and ocean Scripps
where they're very small shouldn't they
have almost no money and then it begins
to change as the Navy begins to fund it
and I tracked this art from the 1930s to
the 1980s where the reverse problem
begins to happen the Navy begins to dial
back in support and the scientists are
worrying about how their go ahead fund
their science going forward
and I discovered a cache of letters of a
group of scientists at Scripps Scripps
Institution of Oceanography some of whom
I knew personally in which they were
talking about this issue and they were
actually going to the Dean at the time
who I also knew saying we need to figure
out what the next big source of funding
for our work is going to be and we think
it's climate change and so these letters
are being read in the 1980s and so I
thought that was pretty interesting
because that's before most of us were
really aware of climate changes I'm just
an ass it's hard for me to remember what
I was I was in the college or whatever
but you know the debate had begun about
that no not really I mean Jim Hansen
testifies in Congress in 1988 ok the
IPCC is cream 1980 so we were talking
about acid rain and ozone holes but not
change hadn't really come into the
public sphere but here the scientists
were talking about it so I thought that
was interesting just by itself like oh
that scientists were actually and in a
way it made sense because Hansen had
testified in 88 so obviously he must
have been working on it for some period
leading up to that so it made me
interested in this sort of earlier
history and I started digging in a bit
more about well what did scientists know
about the question of manmade global
warming back in the 60s 70s 80s and
found a much richer more complicated
story than I had previously known but
also I remember thinking well this seems
a little opportunistic you know and at
the time the contrarians were claiming
oh this is just a big excuse to get
money for your research I was like oh
well I mean this is maybe not an excuse
but it is being put forward as a reason
to get money for their research and so
that made me think that it just needed a
little more investigating so how serious
was this threat you know were they
exaggerating the threat to get funding
because certainly during the Cold War
many historians would argue people did
exaggerate the Soviet threat to get
money for scientific research and other
things so it didn't seem completely
impossible that that was happening here
but when I started digging into it I
found that actually it seemed to me if
anything the scientists had
underestimated the threat and when I
started looking about how much we
actually already knew about this issue
even in the 1970s there were reports
from the National Research Council there
was a very significant report that I
found that had been written by the
Jason's yeah the World Meteorological
Organization had had a big meeting in
1976 I think something 77 something like
that so actually there was quite a bit
of evidence already at that point that
this was potentially a quite serious
issue and so then I just started looking
a bit more into it and so now like so
I'm doing kind of two things at once I'm
researching this earlier
we trying to understand how scientists
came to say the climate change would be
the next big scientific issue in the 80s
but I'm doing this work in the early
2000s when climate change denial is
already a thing and right around the
time I was doing this President George W
Bush responded to an NRC report by
saying well you know I really don't
think there's a consensus on the issue
right and there was this notorious
sentence where he got asked about this
report and he said oh I read the report
put out by the bureaucracy right so yeah
those reports are completely unreliable
yeah yeah they're just they're just just
a bureaucracy what do they know anyway
so I decided to try to answer the
question well is there a consensus
because President of the United States
was saying there wasn't but all the
scientists around me seem to be agreeing
about the issue and the president's
father when he was president was
actually very interested correct
so anyway trying to make a long story
short that led to my publishing my paper
on the scientific consensus on climate
change in 2004 which was the first paper
that analyzed the question of whether or
not there was a consensus among
scientists and little binos to me I
guess some people would now say that I
actually invented the methodology of
consensus analysis which I wasn't doing
deliberately but I guess maybe I did
anyway so I published that article and I
really thought I was naive enough to
think that people were just confused
about the issue you would explain to
them and I wish there was a consensus
show them the data do a quantitative
analysis objective science Citation
Index you know blah blah blah and I even
made a point of saying in the paper
knowing there's a consensus about the
reality of climate change does not tell
us what to do about it the policy
questions are another set of questions
and that requires a different kind of
expertise so I was really quite clear
about that I thought I had been a very
responsible scholar
right and then I got slammed yes just
slammed you no threat threatening phone
calls hostile email attacks by a senator
you know from Oklahoma I mean really
crazy stuff and so this is mid 2000 2004
and I always I say this was my Alice
Through the Looking Glass moment it was
gone down some weird rabbit hole into a
parallel universe of people who thought
that climate change was a liberal
conspiracy and who knows what other
things and so at first it was frankly
what are some scary little frightening I
mean getting through death threats is no
fun you know and I'm thinking I
published a paper in science magazine
I'm getting a death threat this is like
there's something has to be explained
right can't imagine telling your parents
I would like to be a historian of
oceanography and then saying it's a very
dangerous
exactly I know exactly I mean who would
have thought right may I just get got
back from giving a talk in Texas where I
had an armed guard with me the whole day
now I was told they do that for all
their visitors but they just like being
armed anyway so exactly I mean this was
just a very strange experience so and I
feel in this moment there was a nice
piece of luck I guess
I remember thinking well if I were a
scientist like I'd stayed being a you
know strict geologist I wouldn't really
be able to investigate this because it
wouldn't be geology but I'm a historian
so if something has happening I can just
follow it where it leads and that's kind
of what I've done for us now 14 years
it's just been a set of leads and I
followed them and so I'm not really
doing any geology anymore and a lot of
what I'm doing is is only tangentially
related to some of the original
questions that I started out interesting
it in although obviously it all kind of
circles back in the end but I just
started thinking well who are these
people why are they attacking me why is
what I said threatening and why does the
president United States think there's no
consensus about climate science when
there clearly is and that why that set
of why questions led to us about the
emergence of doubt and I know a little
bit about the controversy of course but
still I guess I didn't know too much
about it cuz only while reading your
book did I realize that not only was
there a kind of epistemological
connection between the arguments over
climate change and other arguments like
tobacco or whatever acid rain but it's
the same people it's like there's
there's a handful of people that you can
count on the fingers of one hand and I
these characters show up over and over
again so tell us tell us tell our
podcast audience about this whole story
well so this was the big discovery that
Erik Conway my co-author I made and it
was really Eric who first realized that
something was going on here because I
went to a conference in Germany a very
important famous group the International
Commission for the history of
meteorology so you know very small very
obscure and I gave a talk on a small
element of the history of climate
science some work that was done in the
1960s but at the end of the talk in the
Q&A it came up that I was being attacked
and I had mentioned by name one of the
people who was attacking me and later
that day like in the bar over a beer
Erik Conway who was at the meeting who I
hadn't met yet came up to me and as it
turned out he was writing a book on the
history of atmospheric science at NASA
and a whole section of the book was
about NASA's work on the ozone hole on
ozone depletion and he had come across a
whole stash of materials of people who
had attacked the scientists who worked
on the ozone hole including particularly
sherry Rowland who shared in the Nobel
Prize for that work and so she was being
addicted right he show you Rowland well
what is he he is a he's yes sure
wouldn't I wish that sure he was a great
guy but even would have been even
greater if she was no bet so back in the
80s
shirring 80s and early 90s sherry and
his colleagues had been attacked for
their work on climate on the ozone hole
and Eric said to me well you know the
people who are attacking you it's the
same people who attacked sherry Rowland
and I knew enough about that history not
about the attacks but about the science
I think like one like that's so weird
and then I thought wait did you just say
my name and the same sentence as sherry
Rowland Nobel laureate one of the
greatest most important scientists of
the 20th century without whom we would
all be like dying of ozone depletion you
know related cancer anyway he said yeah
when I get home I'll send you some stuff
so he sent me this package of materials
that he had and it was like to remember
the game mad libs yeah right where you
just substitute the words
was like exactly the same there was a
template and you could take out global
warming and put an ozone hole and it was
identical and it was the same people and
one of them was fred seitz and as you
probably know fred seitz was extremely
famous 20th century physicist that was
the other thing it's not like a merry
band of little crackpots these are big
names exactly right so I'm thinking Fred
Seitz so I was enough of a history of
science to know that you know who he was
and to think why is Fred Seitz doing
this
right and so I just started digging a
little bit trying to forget find out a
little bit more about him and then I hit
what I think I was kind of the big
reveal was was the discovery that he
worked for RJ Reynolds Tobacco and so at
that point I called another colleague my
colleague Robert Proctor and Stanford's
done a law to work on history of tobacco
and I said Robert have you ever heard of
Fred Seitz he goes oh have I ever heard
of Fred Seitz so two days later another
package comes in the mail it's a big
stack of documents about scientist
connections targe emails same thing this
time takeout kind of chains put in
tobacco right and so then we thought oh
there's a story here
yeah it's not just that the argument
sounds similar it's that they're
actually the same arguments we made by
the same people and they thought okay
there's some story that has to be told
and so I put aside the oceanography book
putting on backburner so I'm going to
work on this and and one of your
questions was like you said these are
you know Fred Seitz and the others are
big names they're famous scientists
that's not that they misunderstand the
science correct there has to be some
other set of reasons right and that was
one of the really important things we
really realized early on that in a way
was good that there was just no
possibility that this was scientific
illiteracy right because many people at
the time were assuming that if people
didn't accept kind of science it was
because they didn't understand the
science and therefore if you just
explained the science better more
clearly you know fewer graphs left less
jargon that you would get through to
people and this blew that argument out
of the water right this had nothing to
do and so then the question became well
what does it have to do with and it took
us time you know we spent several years
digging through a lot of materials but
then when we began to find these linkage
to these various libertarian right wing
think-tanks then the story became clear
that this was ideologically motivated it
was driven by anxieties about communism
and the fear that government regulation
of the marketplace was a kind of
slippery slope to socialism and we
actually found places where they said
exactly that in their own words
yes let's draw that out a little bit I
mean when was the argument about smoking
happening seventies well so it's a
little bit complicated the original
argument about smoking use really begins
in the 1960s with the Surgeon General
report and by the 70s it was pretty
clear smoking caused cancer and a host
of other terrible diseases and by the
Aedes people you know there were bans on
smoking in public places people were
starting to win lawsuits against the
tobacco industry in the early 90s the US
Department of Justice filed suit against
them for conspiracy to commit fraud
against the American people so so this
played out over a period of time but
beginning in the 60s I'm running through
the 90s fred seitz started working for
the tobacco companies in 1979 so this is
well after the bulk of the scientific
evidence is clear science had been done
science are basically done at that point
so you know question one why would he
make common cause with the tobacco
industry and then there's a kind of
second round that Fred singer gets
involved with in the early 90s over the
issue of secondhand smoke and that's
it's interesting the tobacco industry
was never admirable in its behavior but
it became even less admirable at this
point because this is when the rubber
really hit the road because up until
this point they had been arguing that
smoking is a personal choice that if
smokers know the risks and choose to
take those risks that's their choice and
in a free society we don't want the
government making that choice for us and
up to a point
that's fits in with you know capitalism
correct so it's not it's not crazy and
it's not a lie right it's a judgement
about what role you think the government
should or should not play in protecting
consumers from dangerous products but
in the late 80s the scientific evidence
became overwhelming that secondhand
smoke also killed people and at that
point the argument about personal choice
is blown out of the water and that's
when the tobacco industry got really
nasty and did some of the more ugly and
nefarious things they did including one
project they had which they call Project
white coat coat which was to who wears
white coats scientists it was to recruit
scientists to be to defend tobacco
because they began to realize that the
industry had lost credibility but if
they could have scientists defending it
that would have more credibility and
particularly journalists they could get
journalists to present both sides of the
story and this technique was highly
effective so if you look at say articles
the New York Times from the 80s very
much like well you know scientists say
this but this you know other guy do this
other scientists and very often it's not
made clear that the scientist defending
the tobacco industry is in fact on the
payroll of this industry well it is one
of the things about how science works in
combination with how law works and
legislation works and journalism works
is that you know even if there are a
hundred people on one side and two
people on the other side it's still two
sides and so you say let's get a
representative from one side and the
other and so just a small number of
scientists who are willing to say that
secondhand smoke is not so bad or the
earth is not warming up can have an
outsized impact for that and the tobacco
industry recognized that and they
exploited it and so that was their whole
strategy right was to create this
impression of a debate and they realized
that you know they only needed a few
people to help them do them if they had
Fred Seitz Fred singer a few others they
could very quickly create the impression
of a significant scientific debate and
of course we've seen that recapitulated
now with climate science yeah I mean you
mentioned 1979 which makes me think of
my days in high school and college when
Ronald Reagan was president and it might
be hard for the youthful podcast
listening audience out there to put
themselves in the mindset of there was a
real threat of nuclear war the least
there was a impression that this is
something that could realistically
happen we need to defend ourselves and
it was really not just a rival
between two countries but a clash of
worldviews of the sort of collectivist
communist view and and our individualist
freedom view and and therefore and
suddenly there's a chain of logic that
says that government regulation and
restriction on industry is sort of a
slippery slope towards communism right
well that's exactly right
and I think there's two important points
I'd like to make about that so one is
that one of the big problems with much
of the thinking that we criticize in
merchants of doubt' is this dichotomies
ation Manichaean Cold War mentality and
it is understandable I mean I'm old
enough to remember the Cold War it
certainly is understandable that in the
context of the Soviet threat it was easy
to slip into a kind of Manichaean
worldview but the reality of course is
that our choices are not simply
totalitarian collectivism on the one
hand and total you know free market
libertarian chaos on the other right
there's a lot of choices in between and
of course there are many countries in
the world particularly in Western Europe
that have a different balance of
free-market principles and government
involvement than we do but it became
very difficult to have that conversation
during the Cold War and I would say that
Ronald Reagan is part of the reason for
that I mean Reagan made it worse that
there was a period under Kennedy Johnson
Nixon particularly under Nixon when we
had they taunt we had you know we saw
perestroika in the Soviet Union there
was a kind of relaxation of hostilities
and an increasing degree of trade with
the Soviet Union increasing degree of
conversation and you know that one of
the tragedies of Richard Nixon was that
he actually had some very significant
foreign policy successes in lessening
the tensions with the Soviet Union and
also had some significant interventions
in the marketplace here in the United
States including you know really
important pieces of environmental
legislation so there was a kind of
middle ground that we actually were
moving to in the 1970s but Reagan
stopped that and he really dialed it
back and and dialed up the rhetoric much
more to something more like what we had
seen in the 1950s where the Soviet Union
was the evil empire there was no
compromise and it was all or nothing and
that kind of all-or-nothing thinking
made it much harder than to talk to
conservatives about something like the
UN Framework Convention on Climate
Change or the Montreal Protocol because
they saw these things as collectivist
communist Akande a threat and that made
it hard for them to recognize that ozone
depletion was also a threat and maybe
actually a worse one and then the second
point about this has to do with nuclear
winter which is a much forgotten but
very important debate from this time
period and actually in our book one of
our early chapters is about nuclear
winter but it's the chapter I think
nobody reads because nobody really sees
like what is nuclear winter have to do
with this it seems like a little out of
place but actually it's usually
important because many of the people who
later became involved in climate change
denial were also involved in the nuclear
winter debate and part of the reason was
because
Reagan's Nixon's response to the threat
of nuclear war was arms control and to
try to dial it back decrease the size of
the stockpile lessen the threat level on
both sides
Reagan rejected that his argument was
the opposite it was that we should build
up our defenses and make the cost of a
nuclear war that much greater so sort of
a return to the mad philosophy the
mutual assured destruction and again you
could argue I mean nobody really knows
there's you know I mean only God knows
which strategy was better so it was
arguable but what Reagan did that was
very troubling and upsetting to many
scientists was that he began to talk
about the possibility of a winnable
nuclear war and that was absurd because
all of the scientific evidence suggested
if we had a massive exchange nobody was
going to win we would all be incinerated
and there was no there was no way to
even conceptualize what is even meant to
win right exactly I once found a memo in
the archive where an oceanographer was
proposing to equip a submarine to
protect the President and vice-president
the event of a massive nuclear exchange
and I remember reading this and thinking
and then when they came back up what
would they govern over right it was like
just right but there was a lot of that
kind of strange thinking during the Cold
War
so when Reagan began to do that a lot of
scientists
spoke up against and said this is
ridiculous there's no such thing as a
nuclear war and the nuclear winter
argument was part of that argument so
then a group of scientists including
Carl Sagan and a number of others
Turco and others did this modeling work
to calculate what would be the effect of
a massive nuclear exchange in terms of
it's all the dust and particulates that
would be left in the atmosphere
afterwards and what they showed was it
would lead to a very dramatic cooling of
the atmosphere so much so that it would
potentially push the earth into a
nuclear winter major crop failure so
that even if you survived the initial
exchange which you probably wouldn't but
even if you did maybe we're in some
outlying place you were up in the Yukon
or something in Australia you would
still be affected that the whole globe
would be affected to be no escaping the
consequences and this strode the Reagan
administration crazy and so it was one
of the early examples of where
scientists are doing science but it has
policy ramification and so the Reagan
administration conservatives went on a
pretty strong campaign to discredit that
work they attacked the work that Carl
Sagan and Seitz was part of that too and
so there's some early hints of this
later story in that debate so it really
does go back to Ronald Reagan it's
really an important the Reagan
administration is a really important
node in this history and you can see how
you know politicians have their
predilections about how to run the
global order and also corporations want
to make money want to avoid being
regulated but the scientists here you
know even if they were in the payroll
I'm gonna guess and tell me if I'm right
they weren't they were even the the
crazy binary scientists who were acting
against the consensus we're doing so
because they believed it was true right
yeah yeah they weren't they weren't
actually in it for the money no no I
mean I think that's one of the important
points of our book is that most of this
is not actually about money I mean
behind the scientists yes there are
industries that have great financial
stakes and certainly the tobacco
industry it was all about money but I
don't think that for Fred Seitz when he
goes to work for r.j. Reynolds it's not
primarily about the money I mean he's
getting paid I'm sure that plays some
role but the ideological justification
is
so really important if not more
important yeah and they I mean they
really got organized right they started
the George Marshall Institute was intact
they they created a think tank they
named it after George C Marshall of the
Marshall Plan you know because of its
role in fighting communism so that's it
already clue about how they're thinking
about this although personally I don't
think George C Marshall would have
agreed what they did but that's just my
opinion
he's not around to say one way or the
other yeah so they created a think tank
and they organized a series of programs
designed particularly aimed at the press
to persuade the press that there was a
big debate that scientists didn't have a
consensus and also to influence public
policy so they sent reports to the White
House and they played a significant role
during the administration of George HW
Bush because as you said President our
first president Bush accepted the
scientific evidence of climate change he
was really the last major Republican
political leader apart from John McCain
to be on board about the science and he
went to Rio de Janeiro for the Earth
Summit in 1992 and he signed the UN
Framework Convention on Climate Change
but already there were people in the
Bush administration who did not want him
to do that and then it was in fact a big
fight in the White House about whether
or not Bush should go to Rio and
Nuremberg and his colleagues played a
significant role in getting they had
written a report an early report
published in 89 that challenged the
scientific evidence they got that
reporting to the White House via Sununu
Johnson Johnson I keep reading his name
because his son is now in politics right
his son is Chris Nuno John Sununu who
was White House chief of staff I think
at the time
so through Sununu they get this report
to the White House and it circulates and
there was one White House staffer who
said oh yes everyone has read it well
and I when I remember when I read that I
thought oh well there you go
so bill nirenberg because of his
position he's director of scripts he's
done all these important things he has
access he has friends in the White House
most scientists don't have that right so
a lot of my scientific colleagues were
sort of moaning and groaning about how
you know politicians didn't seem to
understand climate science and thinking
well yeah yeah so look at this story and
and you know and they're getting this
from building a bird
scientists seems credible right yeah and
and so it is the same people and they're
from tobacco and secondhand smoke and
then the acid rain controversy and the
ozone hole controversy and adventures of
climate change am I missing a
controversy no that's it this the in the
book we have one extra chapter that was
like a slight diversion but we thought
it was important about DDT so these
these Pittsburgh and Josh show didn't
actually get involved with DDT debate
but some of the people they worked with
did and we thought it was important to
include that because it's one of the
places where you see some of the more
outrageous accusations being made in
which they actually take a debate a
scientific debate there has been already
settled for decades and try to reopen it
and so we were thinking why do they want
to reopen the debate about DDT well
because if they do they can discredit
the EPA which was partly created because
of the DDT story and then that can and I
mean look at where we are today right
Rachel Carson is the world's greatest
murderer oh yeah I mean completely
insane
am i completely insane I remember when I
first saw that saying to some people I
give public like just say well it was
Richard Nixon who created the EPA so I
mean why don't they say that Richard
Nixon is the murderer that he has blood
on his hands right so it's also very
sexist it was you know laden with all
kinds of you know gender bias as well
but so that was that DDT story seemed
important in terms of the larger
political context and how these tactics
then spread into them and one of the
amazing things is just how effective
these tactics are and I think that you
know presumably we need to go beyond
certain individual journalistic or
legislative tactics to just the human
psychology of why so many people come on
board I mean you've you found graphs
about the different fraction of
Democrats and Republicans who believe
that human activity is causing global
warming there's no reason if there to be
any correlation between that political
position but there clearly is from a
scientist standpoint there's no reason
but from a cultural standpoint of course
there isn't so that's part of what we're
trying to understand here and so so I
think there's a cup I think there's a
couple of different things going on so
one thing is nobody likes bad news
so if I tell you this is really bad we
have to spend a lot of money now fixing
this problem and someone else tells you
oh no it's fine don't worry who's got
the better mess right so scientists have
a real uphill battle with trying to
persuade people to take climate change
seriously and if someone comes along and
says oh you don't have to worry many
people are going to take that and that's
whether they're Democrats Republicans
independents whatever then there's
wishful thinking I think we're still
thinking plays a big role in people's
lives and sometimes it's a good thing
you know optimism is a good thing yeah
so again I say this is a really serious
problem we need to have a price on
carbon make the price of gas more
expensive someone else comes along says
oh don't worry technological innovation
will solve it once again who's got the
better message right so we're optimistic
we're Americans we believe in
technological progress so let's just
wait technology will solve the problem
and you know the thing is sometimes it
does right so it's not again it's not
crazy but do you sit around and wait for
the magic technology or do you take some
steps and insurance right so that's the
third and then the third thing is the
subject of my new book so shameless plug
no that's over here yeah so Eric I mean
I've just started working on a new
project which is really an attempt to
answer this question why does this
argument about freedom freedom freedom
regulation is bad governments bad
taxations bad the market is good why is
that argument have so much resonance
with the American people when in fact we
know that markets fail pick up any
elementary economics textbook
I mean market failures really Great
Depression 2008 housing bubbles two of
crazes I mean there's lots and lots of
examples of market failures small and
large throughout the entire history of
capitalism so the idea of market failure
shouldn't be a big deal and yet somehow
it is we somehow don't assimilate the
idea that yes markets are often
efficient but sometimes they fail and
sometimes really bad well and a failure
of the market is sort of a failure on
its own terms to make its people money's
it doesn't even work at that but there's
also just you know markets causing bad
outcomes you know that's the second
thing the first thing is markets failing
even on their own terms like a housing
and then the second thing is what
economists call external costs the
market could be functioning well as a
market but not accounting for some
damaging effect and climate change is
that right that so buying and selling
oil gas fossil fuels by themselves not
necessarily a bad thing until we
discover that there's this really
serious unintended side effect and
that's called an external cost and again
this is an economics textbook there's no
secret and yet somehow we operate and we
talk and we speak as if external costs
well they're external right somehow they
don't count because they're external to
the market and that doesn't make sense
and then there's the whole freedom thing
because of course we want freedom I mean
of course freedom is a good thing but
you know there are competing freedoms my
freedom to do certain things impinges on
your freedom to do other things I don't
have the freedom to dump my garbage in
your backyard so why should you have the
freedom to dump your garbage in the
atmosphere and yet the first one we know
is no good right you could have me
arrested if I came and dumped my junk on
your lawn but somehow the freedom of
corporations to dump pollution in the
atmosphere well we've put some limits on
that but not as many as we need so so
these are issues of competing freedom
and again there's a big philosophical
literature about this Isaiah Berlin once
famously said that freedom for wolves
can be death for laughs I used that line
once at a conference at Yellowstone I
thought oh maybe that's not the best
always looking for those good metaphors
but metaphors are very socially
contingent anyway so the point is these
are all things that can be discussed
need to be discussed and we have a
framework through which we could discuss
them and yet somehow that hasn't
happened instead we have this really
pervasive cultural story about the
efficiency of marketplace the magic of
the marketplace that makes it very easy
to persuade people just let the markets
handle it and don't let the government
interfere government's bureaucratic
government is inefficient government is
bad and so Eric and I became interested
in trying to figure out where did that
story come from and especially the
government piece because government's
good we need a government the reason we
government is because if we didn't life
would be nasty perdition some would have
already told me right but that's the
point
Reagan was all about governments the
problem not the solution so we became an
interest in trying to figure out where
that came from
especially because if you think about
the founding fathers right this country
was built on the premise of good
governance that government is essential
and we want to do it right and not just
put in the hands of a monarch or a
dictator but have a kind of structure
that will ensure that governance goes
forward in a reasonable manner that you
know majority rule but with respect to
the views of minorities all those good
things but yet somehow again we've lost
that and now we're in this thing we just
think of governments being bad and
somehow the explanation has to involve
the fact that these this divergence of
attitudes happens you know over time and
also you know more in the United States
than in other similar Western countries
and yes it's not just purely a human
psychological real correct and that's a
really important point right exactly
it's very local because climate change
denial is essentially an American
phenomena I mean it doesn't it exists a
little bit a few other places but not
much probably because they're listening
to us and exactly well I mean in
Australia thoth we know it came from the
United States and was like pushed out to
Australia but in France Germany you know
Switzerland China Brazil I mean kind of
change now it's just not a thing
Argentina Chile I mean you know Japan
Tanzania so this is a very particularly
American story and so any explanation it
has to be about that so this is one
reason why I'm a little skeptical of the
human psychology analysis yes of course
there's a psychological component that's
certainly true but that doesn't explain
why like 90 percent of Germans accepted
climate change is real irrespective of
whether they're conservatives or
liberals and yet in the United States
like 50 percent of Republicans don't
write this so this is a cultural thing
that needs a cultural explanation my
very first podcast guest was Carole
Travers who's a social psychologist and
we talked about you know cognitive
biases cognitive dissonance tribalism
you know and how when you pick a side
you're driven to ex post facto invent
reasons to support your side it means
there's some snowball effect that when
people from the George Marshall
Institute were effective enough and
getting some policymakers to buy
to this picture then that sort of
shifted the political discourse in a way
that the country followed along yeah I
think that's definitely true definitely
and that's I think where the
psychological elements do come in but at
the same time if you are looking to
change the situation then the tribal
story doesn't really help you figure out
how to change it very well but if you
remind people well you know Republicans
didn't always think this I mean like I
say if we go back to Nixon and Bush you
know they were pro-environment
and there's a long history of Republican
environmentalism in this country so part
of my goal is actually to find some way
to recreate that spirit of Republican
environmentalism which I actually agree
with really strong him I go back and I
read Gifford Pinchot I'm like Gifford
were ya or even more recently I spent a
bit of time at the Library of Congress a
few months ago in the papers of Russell
Trane who was the first head of the
Council of Environmental Quality under
Richard Nixon what a great man
I mean some of his speeches you could
dust them off and you could use them
right now and they would still be
pertinent and he talks about all the
reasonable things that you know it seems
to me we should be talking about about
this is a serious problem it doesn't go
away by ignoring it or pretending it
doesn't exist but we want to find
efficient ways to deal with it and he
was actually he was a great man he was
involved in a lot of different forms of
conservation including a lot of it he
got interested in environmentalism
initially through wildlife conservation
like Africa big-game conservation but he
also talked about how ordinary people
have the need to be in beautiful places
and after the urban riots in the 1960s
he gave a big speech in which he showed
that some of the Commission's that had
looked into the causes of the riots
people had talked about the fact that
they didn't have parks in their
communities they just didn't even have a
place where they could sit under a tree
so it wasn't just about preserving
elephants but it was also about just the
way in which nature and natural
environments are important to people on
a daily basis and he saw that and I
thought it's such a what a great man
took whose notion of conservation is so
capacious that it ranges from protecting
the elephants in Africa to making sure
that people and wants have parks I just
thought I was like so but I was like oh
speaking of shameless plugs another
reason
gasps gasps was Joe walleston of the
Wildlife Conservation Society and and he
makes the case that almost all
environmental movements started in
cities you know the people who miss
being out there in the environments that
become activists about trying to protect
it and he's cautiously optimistic that
there's a new equilibrium in our future
if we can get enough people to live in
cities then we can leave nature alone
and it can actually rebound oh that's
interesting well I hope he's right but
that's certainly true I mean right if
you live out in the country or rural
area you can it's easy to take it for
granted
but with the rise of urbanization I mean
the original environmental movement in
the United States with Gifford Pinchot
john d rockefeller Teddy Roosevelt was
all about responding to urbanization and
the impacts they thought that had in
American life
so when you go back into the past
looking at these things I know this is
part of your new book do you have a
title for the new book by the way yes
it's called the magic of the marketplace
: the true history of a false idea very
good yes and is this gonna last I know
that new publishers always want to mess
with your titles so this is a set in
stone I do not well it's never set in
stone but our publisher really likes
this title so I'm thinking that this one
has a good chance of surviving yeah so
you you go back because I just heard you
talk about this yesterday for those who
are listening I know that no you go back
and there's a long history of the United
States of this battle between
corporations and the government trying
to regulate them a little bit right in
child labor is one of them and I was
struck by the fact that maybe the maybe
the first incident on your slide was
emancipation right and it you know for
many reasons one of which it reminds me
like this is still the original sin of
the United States like so many things go
back to the fight over slavery yes well
it's true and I threw that in to be
deliberately provocative most of the
book is going to focus on the 20th
century we're not going to talk about
slavery but it is really important to
recognize that the marketplace gave us
slavery right and that's an extreme
example but it's an important one
because it's a reminder that we don't
actually consider it acceptable to buy
and sell all things we do put limits
we've always placed limits on the
marketplace and the great fight of the
19th century in this country which we
are still dealing with is that some
people thought it was legitimate to buy
sell other people and other people
didn't and so we had to make a choice
and that wasn't a choice that the market
by itself could solve right there was no
magic of the marketplace to resolve the
problem of slavery and ultimately it was
the federal government to put an end to
slavery to emancipation proclaimation so
that's an extreme example but I think
sometimes those extremes are important
for us to kind of put to frame the prom
and then in the book I think we probably
won't talk about slavery because it
would be kind of a diversion but we will
start with the debate over child labor I
think that's a really great example
because almost no in the United States
today would defend child labor although
interestingly enough I actually did a
little googling to see if I could find
someone who did in there out there but
they will send you emails after your
book comes out they probably will oh
that's particular when I found was
actually someone relatively prominent
who defended it in third-world countries
on the grounds that they needed because
they're so poor which I think has the
argument backwards I think you get out
of poverty to education and you can't
educate your children if they're working
in factories but nevertheless the point
is the vast vast majority of us would
not sanction child labor and so it's
important for us to realize that well
but we had to fight for that because the
free market sanctioned child labor and
so how do we end child labor through
regulation through laws that said no and
it starts modestly it starts with
restrictions for children under 12
it starts with certain kind of certain
industries like mining
I mean it's staggering to think but in
the 19th century you had four-year-olds
five year old six-year-olds working in
mines right and those children almost
none of those children made it to
adulthood so today we wouldn't consider
that socially acceptable and one of the
things you said was that it was more
dangerous to be a child working on the
railroad than to be fighting in World
War one I know yeah and but it did
happen and you know your example of the
foreign countries child labor in foreign
countries makes me think that there is
kind of an interesting game theory
aspect to this right like if your
philosophy is you should let every
individual or every family do whatever
they want then sure there will be
circumstances under which an individual
family is forced to send the
kids to labor because that makes them
more money but you can also imagine
changing the circumstances so that that
is not the best thing for them and
that's and that that kind of logic leads
you directly to say that we need some
kind of intervention in the market
correct and I think invoking game theory
is useful here because it's a reminder
that you can end up in a race to the
bottom right and in a sense that was
what happened with manufacturing in this
country
early on when people when states first
tried to pass laws the manufacturers
objected because they said well we'll be
disadvantaged relative to the state
next-door and that was true you know
right and that's so that's why
ultimately we needed federal legislation
to create a level playing field so that
a company that didn't hire child labor
wouldn't be disadvantaged against
another company that did but then but
it's also there's a little optimistic
side of it which is that we don't have
time labor before we correctly got rid
of that and another great example is
smoking of course in secondhand smoke
you can't smoke on airplanes anymore
that was the example of a fairly rapid
transition from no this is my absolute
right to how could you ever imagine
correct I know and so that's a great
example because it's a reminder that
things can change and sometimes they
change faster than we might expect and
that's my hopeful conclusion about
climate change I mean we're in a pretty
bad spot right now we've wasted 30 years
we've were really behind the eight ball
particularly in terms of technological
innovations we've lost a lot of useful
time but at the same time we also know
that if we really commit to this reject
denial get serious about doing something
then things can happen pretty quickly
and particularly once technolon of
technological innovation gets going you
know then it can have a kind of positive
feedback effect right and you see that
already here in California I mean for me
just coming back to visit having been
living in Massachusetts for the last
five years there are so many more
electric cars here than there are in
Massachusetts and some of that is
weather but a lot of that is the social
contagion of you know your neighbors got
a Tesla and starts raving about what a
great car it is and how much money
they're saving and you think oh well I
could do that too right or maybe I can't
afford a Tesla but I can get this new
what is it the bolt it has a 300-mile
into it
I mean you begin to talk about it and
it's it begins to seem plausible
and then because they're more like to
charge it electric cars there's more
charging stations which then makes it
more feasible and then you're in a
virtuous cycle and certainly with solar
power they've been several articles
recently about trying to explain how it
came to be the fact that solar power has
gotten so much cheaper so quickly the
answer is well you put a lot of effort
into developing it you know that's both
because of incentives and also because
of demand and exactly really changed the
picture right and the regulatory
incentives make a big difference there's
been some good work on this that one of
the key items that helped contribute to
the decline in the cost of solar power
was the German feed-in tariffs because
when Germany so Germany passed a law
saying that any consumer who generated
solar power would be guaranteed that
they could sell it into the grid and be
paid for it when that happened a lot of
consumers wanted to do it then knowing
that there would be a market some of the
big companies like Siemens then got
involved in solar power production once
you get a big company involved in the
efficiencies right then the market
starts to work right the efficiencies of
scale and stuff but you needed you
needed that boost that initial incentive
and the guarantee of market share or not
guarantee but the likelihood of market
share through the regulatory structure
and then once the market gets going
often it is efficient and often it does
work well but often you need like some
kind of boost to get it over the initial
hump well and also I mean you made the
point that there's this picture that
it's either the market or its central
planning right and and if that's the
battle then you know you can easily see
why people would favor the market market
it's really good at finding clever
solutions do you know maximizing
whatever it's trying to maximize but the
government can play a role without
central planning and figuring out what
you should be maximized because it's
hardly to toilet Arianism to live in a
country where you have a feeling tax and
in fact they have feed-in tariffs in
Texas yeah there you go yeah so what
would you say that you've learned
strategically from all this like in
terms of the the battle about climate
change is very far from over obviously
from looking back into the origins of
this contrarian ISM and so forth does
that suggest any way that those of us
who believe that climate change is a
real problem should be acting
well that's a big question of course but
I guess the main thing that I always
come away with is the realization that
if you want to have change social
technological cultural change in an
issue that involves scientific evidence
where the science plays a large part or
the whole part of making the case for
why this change is needed then you have
to do both together the science and the
science and the social change have to
work hand in hand it's not enough just
to give people scientific information
because if they don't like that
information then all the psychological
factors we already talked about kick in
but if you don't give them the science
then there's no reason and then they're
like well why should I even be bothering
about this and the tobacco story is the
clearest evidence of that so we did get
social change in tobacco and it was a
combination of scientific evidence that
clearly showed smoking killed people
including their innocent children and
bartenders and flight attendants but
also you had a social movement to
communicate that information it wasn't
really the scientist who drove the
social change right it was groups like
the American Cancer Society who had
advertising campaigns the Surgeon
General and also communities that began
to pass ordinances to ban smoking in
public places lawyers who took on
lawsuits to file suit against the
tobacco industry so a whole set of
different groups of which science was a
was an important part it was a crucial
part but it didn't do it on its own and
so I think that's a really important
lesson for scientists to realize that
scientists need to work in conjunction
with activists politicians business
leaders lawyers Justice Department
officials whoever it is right and
conversely activists have to be smart
about the science they have to do their
homework learn the science make sure
that what they say is correct you know
that they don't neither underestimate or
overestimate the threat but be honest
about what we know and I always say you
don't have to exaggerate the threat
because the truth is bad enough yeah
and it's a tough lesson a little bit I
think that scientists are very willing
to hear what you have to say if you say
well what we need is more scientific
education and critical thinking right
and but when you say no we actually have
to organize
get our hands dirty politically as hard
you know institutionally places like the
National Academy of Sciences don't want
to get too political right but the earth
is in danger then maybe something needs
to be done exactly exactly right and
Ralph Cicero him to his credit before he
passed said something along those lines
yeah I mean it goes against the grain
for scientists because we've been taught
that we shouldn't do that that we to be
objective means we have to be not
political and it threatens our
objectivity and most scientists don't
really like politics I mean you go into
science because you like the idea of
clear answers you know there's a
definite answer two plus two equals four
you know not somewhere between three and
five will win out exactly I still
believe in evidence
all these good things that are all very
lovely and wonderful but in the real
world they don't suffice it's not that
they're not it's a necessary but not
sufficient condition and that's just
really hard for the scientific community
I think to really take on board in a
serious way but you know Ralph cicerone
went through the whole ozone debate and
he came around to feeling that that was
the case and that the scientific
community did need to be involved
because the facts don't speak for
themselves and there are lots and lots
of people out there who want to reject
the facts and you mentioned being
objective which reminded me one other
point I just wanted to bring up you know
we've been in some sense we've been
giving grief to conservatives here right
because those are the ones who are
allied with these particular denialist
strategies liberals are not always both
both that of course liberals can be just
as crazy and wrong and you know maybe I
don't know the anti vex controversy
isn't example well that's a really
important one though to be clear about
because there have been some people have
been tempted to say that actually anti
vaccination is the left-wing version and
that's false we have data on who opposes
vaccination and it just it doesn't
really line up with Democrat Republican
concerns there's a stereotype here in LA
yeah but that's false that's false and
it's been promoted I think by some
people who should know better I think
sometimes what happens is people like
ourselves who want who want to make the
point of course no it's not just
conservatives but in this
particular issue that we're dealing with
for a set of cultural and ideological
reasons it's turned out to be
conservatives and in principle it could
be liberals too so then we look for an
example of that and so the anti-vaccine
advanced same thing looks like it could
be that because certainly you know Marin
County has a high rate of
anti-vaccination but the evidence
actually doesn't support that
anti-vaccination is a kind of
interesting mixture of conservative
Christians home schoolers hippy liberals
people who had some bad experience with
the medical establishment and some other
you know it's just there's a lot of
different reasons that have come
together and then you have celebrities
who promote it so it's a bit of a
different kettle of fish but in a way
that's good because it's a reminder that
there can be many different reasons why
people reject science I've studied this
particular phenomenon where conservative
pro-market ideology has led people to
reject climate science but there are
many other things that could lead people
to reject science and so you know if if
and when we find liberals turning
against science then we'll have to deal
with that too yeah even if you try to be
as fair as possible it's just if you
look at the you know political
leadership in the two parties there's an
imbalance exactly but we don't find in
general Democratic leaders telling us
that climate scientists are just in it
for the money yeah that's true
and so in that case they may be the
final question you mentioned that both
scientific knowledge and sort of
political activism is is the the kind of
strategy you need is there any sort of
more purely political legislative get
leaders of the Republican Party on board
kind of strategy here I mean is there
are they too invested now in this
message that they can't give it up even
if internally they don't believe it well
I think they are very invested and I
think a lot of them have backed
themselves into a corner but on the
other hand you know people can change
and you know it's a little tricky using
Richard Nixon as an exemplar of anyone
because he's not change it is one of our
more successful presidents but and he
had a certain fatal flaw that led to his
downfall
but if you
for the moment separate Watergate from
the rest of his presidency Richard Nixon
was one of the most virulent
anti-communist in American politics in
the 1950s and was famous for really
unprincipled hostile attacks on
political opponents famously Helen
Gahagan who was not a communist but he
accused her of being and yet he was the
one who you know he went to China but
exactly and that was what people always
said that he could do it because he had
this reputation of being so
anti-communist that if anyone could do
it it would be him so that actually
gives us an interesting suggestion right
that actually some of the most virulent
kind change deniers have an opportunity
here now to do something big and
actually to be heroes and even if even
to find people like me being grateful
the world the world correct and so there
is an opportunity to get themselves how
question is whether there's any light in
between doing that but just committing
suicide right well that's because right
that's the big fear I mean Nixon was
president when he went to China so he
had the position to do that and it's
obviously much more difficult for
someone lower at a lower rank but it's
not impossible to imagine a coalition of
Republican governors or a coalition of
Republican mayor's or coalition of
Republican members of Congress stepping
out and doing this and have it not be
political suicide we're allowed to dream
right thanks so much
[Music]
you
[Music]